ya hemos visto muchas formas de escribir
ecuaciones lineales por ejemplo hemos
visto los de la forma pendiente ordenada
al origen verdad pendiente ordenada
origen y esta forma esencialmente se
escribe como de igual a mx más vez y lo
que sabemos es que m es justamente la
pendiente mientras que la b es la
ordenada
origen verdad la pendiente es una medida
de qué tan inclinada está la línea
mientras que la ordenada al origen nos
dice la altura la cual intercepta la
línea al eje de verdad y bueno
esencialmente en mi vez son constantes
la gráfica que represente a esta
ecuación intersecta al eje y entonces en
el 0,10 verdades es la ordenada al
origen pero bueno esto ya lo hemos
platicado bastante lo hemos discutido en
otros vídeos verdad entonces también
hemos visto otra forma que es la forma
punto pendiente tenemos la forma punto
pendiente
muy bien tenemos la forma punto
pendiente donde esencialmente podemos
ver la pendiente la pendiente y que de
hecho es la letra m vamos a ponerlo como
igual y además vamos a necesitar un
punto verdad un punto que pase por esa
línea o que sea solución de la ecuación
lineal entonces tendremos el punto x
igual a igual a b y con esta información
podemos construir la forma punto
pendiente que es de menos ve igual a m
por x menos a muy bien y de hecho estas
dos formas son equivalentes se puede
llegar de la una a la otra a través de
manipulaciones algebraicas verdad ahora
bien lo que quiero revisar en este vídeo
es otra forma que quizás ya hayas visto
y que conocemos como la forma estándar
la forma estándar muy bien la forma
estándar esencialmente se escribe muy
sencillo es una constante a que
multiplica x más otra constante b que
multiplica y esto nos debe dar igual a c
muy bien entonces lo que quiero hacer es
checar para qué es buena esta forma y
para que ve otras cosas no lo están muy
bien y vamos a hacerlo a través de un
caso práctico digamos que tenemos la
ecuación
9 x + 16 ye igual a 72 muy bien entonces
es justamente de la forma estándar
verdad y en realidad la forma estándar
es muy útil para encontrar la ordenada
al origen y también la arcis a al origen
verdad por ejemplo no sé quizás
deberíamos hacer una tablita
una tablita digamos que tenemos equis y
tenemos que muy bien entonces para
encontrar la abscisa al origen es cuando
y es igual a cero verdad es la
intersección con el eje x que justamente
es el eje de las abscisas o bien
podríamos hacer x igual a 0 y eso
corresponde encontrar la ordenada al
origen verdad entonces qué pasa si ya
vale 0
si llévale 0 entonces este 16 no nos
importa y tendríamos que preguntarnos
por qué número hay que multiplicar a 9
para que nos dé 72 verdad entonces
tendríamos que multiplicar 9 por 8 para
que nos dé 72 entonces xs8 muy bien y de
hecho vamos a graficar este punto es el
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
este es el 80 esta es la abscisa al
origen muy bien ahora qué pasa si x es
igual a 0 entonces vamos a localizar nos
sobre el eje y si x es igual a cero
tendremos que quizás debería bajar un
poco tendremos que 16 es igual a 72 y
entonces ya tendría que ser 72 sobre 16
que esto es esencialmente
bueno podríamos hacer las cuentas y
vemos que es 4.5 muy bien entonces la
intersección con el eje y es 4.5 verdad
sí sí a lo mejor no estás muy seguro
puedes sacar la calculadora y hacerlo
por tu propia cuenta entonces si
nosotros ponemos este punto sobre
digamos este este eje tendríamos 1234
más o menos por ahí está este punto que
es la ordenada al origen entonces la
línea que o la gráfica de esta ecuación
lineal es esencialmente la línea que
conecta a esos dos puntos que más o
menos debería verse
o así muy bien ahí está nuestra línea
que conecta a esos dos puntos y por
supuesto esta línea se extiende en ambas
direcciones muy bien esta es la línea
que corresponde a la ecuación 9 x + 16
igual a 72 muy bien entonces lo que yo
mencioné hace unos momentos es que esta
forma estándar es buena para algunas
cosas y ya vimos que es relativamente
buena para encontrar la ordenada al
origen y la abscisa al origen verdad
las otras dos formas no son tan buenas
para encontrar estos dos puntos verdad
bueno aunque la forma pendiente ordenada
al origen efectivamente nos dice
inmediatamente quién es la ordenada al
origen tampoco es muy claro de aquí
quién es la abscisa al origen verdad
ahora bien por ejemplo si consideramos
la punto pendiente pues de aquí no es
muy claro cuál es la ordenada al origen
y la abscisa al origen entonces la forma
estándar nos ayuda bastante a determinar
estos dos puntos sin embargo la forma
estándar es mala o no es no es muy
conveniente para encontrar la pendiente
cosa que en los otros casos sí fue
bastante bueno verdad la pendiente está
explícitamente en estas dos formas así
que vamos a tener que trabajar un poco
para calcular la pendiente por ejemplo
si nosotros nos movemos de x de este
punto a este otro punto verdad estamos
pensando que nos movemos de aquí hacia
la izquierda tenemos un cambio en x
igual a menos 8 si nosotros nos movemos
de 0 a 4.5 y tendremos un cambio en y de
4.5 4.5 entonces la pendiente es muy
fácil de calcular con esto porque
simplemente es la división de estos dos
verdad tendríamos el cambio en jake es
4.5 dividido entre el cambio en x que es
menos 8 y por supuesto como no nos gusta
dejarlo así podríamos multiplicar arriba
por 2 y abajo también por 2 y nos que
- 9 dividido entre 16 y esta es la
pendiente que quizás te parecerá
bastante curioso que este número dado
que esta es la forma estándar verdad
entonces para calcular la pendiente
tuvimos que hacer un poco más de trabajo
podría ser que utilices ambos puntos
para calcular la pendiente o bien
podríamos llevarlo a la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen esas vamos a hacerlo
vamos a hacerlo digamos con amarillo
tenemos la ecuación 9 x + 16 igual a 72
lo que podríamos hacer o lo que tenemos
que hacer más bien es despejar de verdad
restamos 9 x de ambos lados y tendremos
16 igual a menos 9 x
72 y ahora dividimos en todos lados
entre 16 verdad entonces tendremos que
igual a menos 9 sobre 16 x más 72 entre
16 que de hecho ya lo habíamos calculado
y es justamente 4.5 muy bien entonces
justamente estamos obteniendo 4.5 verdad
que es la intersección con el eje y y la
pendiente que ya lo habíamos calculado
también y es menos 9 entre 16 así que
eventualmente podemos recopilar toda
esta información pero quizás tendremos
que trabajar un poco más